écoute moi ah ah
débat
je t'en prie
[Musique]
je te jure
m
[Applaudissements]
alors personnellement moi perso j'en
conviens pas changé alors moi j'ai
qu'une question de basquiat je t'aime
énormément humainement mais comment tu
t'es retrouvé dans une émission de
chansons
c'est sûr que c'est de la chance pour
nous tu crois
[Rires]
le plus fort ce que le public a accroché
mais parce que - ont toujours voté pour
moi donc consulté peut-être le fait que
je me prenne pas au sérieux et que je
fasse le condom comme audi se retrouver
là ta posture et ben non j'ai pas
poursuivre et on est venu me chercher
j'étais sur une plage moi j'étais
pompier en plage du côté de
saint-jean-de-luz bien est ce que tu
connais bien oui on est venu me chercher
en disant voilà ce que tu vas faire un
jeu où il faut chanter à la télé donc
j'ai cru à une blague au départ et puis
de cette blague c'est devenu une énorme
blague d'éditer le bios hâter le beau
gosse a wave le bec ça me permettre
heureusement qu'il était là parce que
franchement ça a mis l'ambiance moi tu
m'étonnes
iris est impliqué franchement en plus
riches hop bam la plus belle jennifer
oui ok
karine magnifique aussi mais la plus
près on va dire et me voilà jennifer
s'est bien passé le géniteur très bien
passé vous voyez encore tu vas pas du
tout non pas du tout du tout non plus
côté s'il a rappelé dans ce numéro que
tu veux non je n'ai après d'ailleurs
j'ai pas de baisser c'est bien qu'elle
devait se comporter avec ses ex quand
même moi je la page apparaît si j'avais
me suis pas sûr qu'elle va me revoir non
plus aux ordres mais ça c'est pas on
avec un truc sympa c'était très bien
j'ai fait une choix de carrière vous
êtes revenu l'été dernier pour
l'instrument tf1 s'est vu très vite way
sur la jccm a passé bon on l'a vu juste
le temps d'enregistrement donc on n'a
pas eu trop le temps
l ouest archers pas là beaucoup de
boulot quoi donc d'accord on l'a vu vite
fait brièvement voilà mais c'était très
bien et fait une belle carrière est
réussi et tant mieux pour elle et elle
le mérite et forcément souviens toi
parce qu'un jour tu peux tu es plus le
château tu décides de partir voilà qui à
londres alors tu es une anecdote la
douane qu'une anecdote je suis dans le
bureau de la directrice alex alors
joubert qui me dit jean pascal qu'est ce
qui se passe j'en ai marre je me casse
jaune et bleu tu de ce jeu je m'en vais
bon écoute ok il faut que tu te reposes
tu vas partir quelques jours se mettre
au vert j'ai dit ok je vais chez moi
elle me dit non partout sauf en france
et moi nb si le coeur je suis un peu
londres tu sais petit mec du sud est
peut-être ce voyage aux lieux dire cuba
ah ouais il est je suis parti c'est très
joli lormes oui il a plus de quatre
jours comme ça qu'on verra sur les
images mais j'en garde un bon souvenir
seul à londres et quand tu reviens en
prime sont des gens qui décident de
garder ça c'est exceptionnel le public a
été depuis depuis 20 ans le public c'est
chaque jour mais vrai pour que tu
voulais arrêter c'est génial comme
histoire c'est très particulier comme un
psychologiquement quand même comme
expérience pourquoi il ya un moment où
il ya des coups dans le château on est
on est entre nous c'est une bulle donc
envie qu entre nous donc il ya des coûts
de certaines psychologiquement c'est
difficile en a qu'une minute du
téléphone dans les coupes et c'est il
faut pas craquer et moi humainement
puisque en plus moi je suis entier je
craque souvent ça arrive j'ai dit je
m'en vais parce que ça va j'ai pas je
suis pas chanteur c'est pas mon job
qu'est ce que je fais c'est parce que
nous extérieurement mais nous c'est
vraiment ce qu'on voit c'est ce que je
veux montrer maintenant c'est vous
chantez avec des stars qu'on ne compte
pas d'âge il ne reverra plus est jamais
allé frapper à l'essai par ne ment
jamais vu mois plus tôt mais chanteur
florent pagny mes idoles qui ont été là
mais avec tout le monde mais tout seul
avec une star
on a toujours je jure que je vais
t'arranger sage et de faire venir une
star ici à bévilard ou n'importe quoi tu
vas chanter avec je te jure